redon de 152 137 245 y 354 a la centena
más cercana que es otra manera de decir
que debemos redondear estos números al
múltiplo de 100 más cercano pensemos en
cada uno de ellos tenemos aquí una recta
numérica que va de 100 200 300 a 400
comencemos analizando a 152 bueno vamos
a ubicarlo en la recta numérica esto es
100 estos 150 estos 200 152 va a estar
más o menos por acá
aquí va a estar 152 aquí tenemos dos
opciones el múltiplo de 100 por encima
de 152 que es 200 o el múltiplo de 100
que está por debajo de 152 que es 100 a
qué dirección debemos ir si estamos
redondeando a la centena más cercana a
la centena nos tenemos que fijar en el
número que se encuentra un lugar a la
derecha de donde queremos redondear en
este caso son las decenas y aquí tenemos
un 5 y este 5 es mayor o igual a 100 así
que vamos a redondear hacia arriba este
152 nos redondeamos a 200 en la recta
numérica vemos que esta parte está más
cercana al 200 que al 100 de hecho aquí
son 48 unidades de diferencia con
respecto a 52 que hay desde el 100 a
este punto así que ya redondeamos el
primero veamos el siguiente el siguiente
vamos a ubicarlo en la recta numérica es
300 150 137 pues va a estar más o menos
por acá 137 de nuevo tenemos dos
opciones podemos redondear lo hacia
arriba a 200 a la centena por encima de
esta cantidad o a la centena por debajo
de ella el múltiplo de 100 debajo de
éste es el cual vamos a elegir
nuevamente nos fijamos si queremos
redondear en las centenas vemos el
número que está a la derecha de la
centena que queremos redondear este
estrés y la regla nos dice que si este
número es mayor o igual a 5 redondeamos
hacia arriba y si no vamos a redondear
hacia abajo en este caso vamos a
redondear hacia 100 porque ese 13 es
menor a 5
aquí vamos a redondear a 100 y eso es
mucho más evidente ya que aquí
gráficamente vemos que este punto está
muchísimo más cercano al 100
que de lo que está al 200 hagamos lo
mismo para 245 aquí los invito a que
pausa en el vídeo y traten ustedes de
encontrar cuál es el redondeo que aplica
hacer esto les ayudará mucho a
comprender bien esto del redondeo bueno
entonces analizamos 245 lo ubicamos
donde está que en la recta numérica 200
250 y 300 245 está un poquito abajo de
250 estará por acá 245 aquí en nuestras
opciones hacia arriba son 300 y hacia
abajo son 200
entonces que dice me fijo si quiero
redondear las centenas me fijo en el
número que se encuentra a la derecha de
estas es el 44 es menor que 5 así que
vamos a redondear hacia abajo vamos a
redondear a 200 aquí estamos viendo en
la recta numérica que en efecto este
punto es más cercano a 200 que a 300
aquí hay 45 unidades de distancia y aquí
hay 55 unidades de diferencia bueno
finalmente analicemos el 354
354 lo ubicamos en nuestra recta
numérica es 350 está un poquito por
encima estará aquí 354 nuestras opciones
hacia abajo el múltiplo que está por
debajo de 354 el múltiplo de 100 es 300
y el múltiplo de 100 que está por encima
es 400 queremos redondear en centenas
nos fijamos para ver que hay en el
número que está a la derecha de este y
es un 5 de acuerdo con la regla si este
número es mayor o igual a 5 se redondea
hacia arriba 5 pues es igual a 5 así que
vamos a redondear hacia arriba aplica el
400 y efectivamente vemos esta marca
está más cercana a 400 de lo que está al
recuerden que como aquí estamos
redondeando a las centenas el valor que
nos va a interesar evaluar es el de las
decenas las unidades no las tomamos en
cuenta para nada